Save the Children office is the newest
terrorist target in Afghanistan Isis
claims responsibility for a suicide car
bombing and rampage this morning at
least two people were killed in the
attack in the eastern city of Jalalabad
it follows another high-profile assault
at a hotel in the capital Kabul four
Americans were among the 22 people who
were killed over the weekend two more
Americans were wounded David Martin is
at the Pentagon David good morning good
morning the Trump administration is five
months into a new Afghan strategy that
is supposed to turn a stalemate into a
win but so far it has been unable to
stop terrorists from killing American
citizens and others in Kabul
eyewitnesses said six Taliban fighters
roamed the halls of the Intercontinental
Hotel looking for foreigners to kill
some guests escaped over balconies while
others hid under beds or in bathtubs it
took nearly 14 hours for Afghan
commandos to take back the hotel and by
then 22 were dead many more wounded the
Taliban has claimed responsibility we
don't have any proof of that yet nearly
seven years ago the Taliban claimed
responsibility for a similar attack on
the intercontinental which left at least
21 dead
more recently 41 people were killed last
month in the bombing of a cultural
center and 150 in a truck bombing last
May after 16 years of war and 2400
American combat deaths the Afghan
capital is so unsafe visitors have to
take a helicopter from the airport to
the US Embassy and the blast walls
around the city keep getting higher and
higher it's a country at war and it's a
capital that is under attack
General John Nicholson the top American
commander in Afghanistan told Larry
Logan of 60 minutes the new US strategy
relies on Afghan ground troops to do the
fighting backed up by American advisers
and air strikes there are currently
about 13,000 US troops in Afghanistan
and Nicholson said there are no plans
for any major increases this is it right
I mean there's no more this is the
endgame yes this is the endgame this is
a policy that can deliver a win
a win means forcing the Taliban to
negotiate an end to the fighting and
Nicolson estimates it will take two
years for the new strategy to produce
results in the meantime topple will
remain a target for high-profile attacks
not just by the Taliban but by any of
the 21 terrorist groups that operate in
Afghanistan Gail all right David thank
you